and tonight ted's forecast really a key
part of our top story and impacts you
the most thank you for joining us on 8
news now at 11 i'm brian loftis and i'm
denise valdez so the air quality affects
us all and we have team coverage for you
tonight orco mana has been out in the
smoke all day but we get back to ted now
because these air advisories are pretty
serious business tip yeah denise
obviously because we do have the small
particular matters that in that smoke
that can actually aggravate the lungs
that's why that smoke advisor that we
talked about was supposed to end today
but now has been extended through this
week air quality right now in the
moderate category smoke of course
moderate ozone unhealthy readings but
that's for the uns for the sensitive
groups and that also is directly related
to that smoke so our current surface
smoke at this hour still shows some
thick haze over our area but thickest
over tonight county and over to inyo
county right now with some clearing off
towards the east coming up i'm going to
show you the future cast on when this
smoke will finally be out of here but
first we're going to go to orco mana who
has details on how to protect yourself
from all this wildfire smoke that has
enveloped the region orco good evening
hey there teddy well it might be a
little hard to tell because it's so dark
out right now but you might be able to
it's very scary i could i could be
triggered at any time and it could
trigger me into going into the hospital
moselle williams suffers from asthma and
says the wildfire smoke spilling into
the las vegas valley from california is
causing some painful problems it's
almost like suffocating williams says
she's now using this nebulizer for
breathing treatments far more frequently
i'm having to do it twice a week just so
i can kind of clear my lungs and be able
to breathe and take deep breaths she
also makes sure the air in her home is
clean we have air purifiers in every
room purifiers can be expensive but
there is a cheaper alternative you can
buy something like an fpr10 furnace air
filter for about 20 dollars and also a
normal box fan and then all you have to
do is place that filter behind the fan
and then use some tape to put that
filter in place behind that fan and then
when you turn the fan on the air that
goes through the fan is much cleaner
keep your windows and doors closed and
change your air filters experts say that
advice is more crucial than ever with
vegas seeing wildfire smoke during three
of the past four years they say small
particles from the smoke can be
dangerous those can get deeper into your
lungs so that's clearly going to be a
health issue especially for those with
breathing sensitivities that's why
williams is doing everything she can to
be safe i have to be a lot more cautious
now
smoke advisory for clark county goes
right through this friday but experts
keeping an eye on things because of
shifting wind patterns we'll have more
for you on the air quality on
eightnewsnow.com